and we have a
very important special topic that we're
going to be talking about is ramadan
and we're with our esteemed guest dr
haddad how are you shay alhamdulillah
how are you how is your ramadan it's
good going good alhamdulillah
how was yours how was your ramadan
excellent
excellent one of the best ramadans and
by the way
subhanallah i don't know for whatever
reason so many brothers
and sisters they confirmed that this
ramadan is
maybe better than all the previous
ramadan
which is really alhamdulillah very good
news mashallah
so tell us for the for the audience uh i
didn't get a chance to read your bio but
i mean for those that don't know you so
you have you're someone who
actually tell us fill us in i mean you
have like a student of knowledge check
your muftik
akadi uh you're kind of like a judge
right
you're at that level where you you know
judge a lot of matters between family
disputes marital disputes
what's your official title well see
well the issue of title is very
subjective
and inshallah maybe sometime in outside
ramadan we can talk about
this because in ramadan yani is better
that we focus on the
main issues yeah and in order to give
more time for ibadah
yeah yeah so the only the reason we ask
is because the advice that you're going
to give you know sometimes
it's important some people like well who
is this guy to give me advice you know
what i'm saying you ever
hear come on man i'm a big celebrity you
don't worry about that
okay may not preserve you protect you
uh before we get into the main topic we
talk we want to talk about because it's
a sad
um but uh realistic um thing that's
happening you were addressing that i was
listen we were
listening to a talk you were giving last
week i believe and you talked about
brothers actually who are fasting you
gave an example
family members and wasting their fast
because they haven't been on speaking
terms for
so many years so that's the topic we'll
be talking about
boycotting family members cutting ties
of kinship especially now because we
don't want to lose our fast and our good
deeds we see in the west
examples i am warning the young
people yeah and not only the young
people the old people from this
grave sin which is what which is
cutting the ties off kinship
and see see how many people are looking
for
solutions they have depression they have
anxiety they have
other mental illnesses a check in their
life
you will see that they are not
maintaining the ties of kinship
and subhanallah wallahi today today yeah
today a sister rang me and she was
complaining to me about her brother who
is above
50 50 years of age
and the way he is treating his father
who
is suffering from dementia
yeah now i said to her one of the things
that i said to her
tell him that your father will pass away
you will become old and allah
will punish you in the dunya before the
akhirah and will send
upon you those who will humiliate
you yeah as a result of being what
ungrateful to your father yeah
so i am warning every single one
against what against the the
break of the ties of the the
ties of kinship and look look
see when allah allah created
in the hadith when allah created the
creation
what happened the ties of kinship
stood and said
we are appealing to you and then allah
allah said
what do you want yeah
the charge of kinship says
refuge in you from those who cut
me off so allah said
okay i will please you i will look after
those who look after you
and i will cut off those who cut you
off brothers and sisters
you will not have a successful life
if you in particular
cut the ties of kingship in particular
to your parents or with your parents let
me say that again
maybe you can yeah brothers and sisters
you will never be successful
in your life whatsoever
if you don't maintain the ties of
kinship
especially to your own parents you know
subhanallah recently recently
uh one brother attended a course with
one of the big
organization we are not yeah maybe it's
not good to mention their name
yeah because they want to keep
everything confidential
and every year they train
over i think 200 something thousand
people
around the world you know in the first
day of the training
these are non-muslims none kind of
christians
this is just simple coaching yeah
self-development
the first day they are asking the
students to do what
to call their parents and to fix
their relationship with their
part of their training exactly part of
the training
and that this is the first thing they do
in their training
and then we see subhan allah our deen
yeah our deen he our dean is encouraging
us to do this
simply so allah talked upon himself that
he will look
after those who what maintain the ties
of kinship
uphold the terms of kinship and cut off
those
who cut the ties of kenship and then the
prophet salallahu
so strong so strong the translation of
this
if you go away turn away from my
guidance
what will happen yeah you will what
you will cut the touch of kinship
and as a result of this number one
the curse of allah allah will happen to
you
number two allah allah will turn you to
be what
to be deaf and then number three
you will not see the truth you will not
find a happy person i
challenge you i you don't find a happy
person
that he is rude to his parents in
particular
subhanallah let me let me ask you shay
uh i'm going to get a bunch of questions
before we conclude
because we're limited on time can you
just uh let's start off with that story
and then i'll jump in i want i want to
get some of your uh feedback on some
ayahs from the quran
and some hadith that are revolving
around this topic if you can tell us are
they authentic
and also your comments on the hadith
that are related to this
but let's start off with this story that
you mentioned just real quickly the
story of
us getting into ramadan and then you had
these brothers that story that you were
narrating
it was really touching yeah so this is
actually
this is a true case we had it just
before the end of ramadan
and it was really this is was amazing
this is uh a brother he brought his
father-in-law
yeah see the brother brought his
father-in-law
to me because what he wants me to speak
to his father-in-law
regarding the importance of what
maintaining the ties of kinship
and to start to talk to his brothers
for the last 15 years he did not
speak to them and they are
living all of them are living in the uk
forget about even living in the uk even
if they
live abroad now okay we can you are in
america and i am in the
in london and we are communicating yeah
so that is not an execution
for 15 years and see
what i cannot believe until now
although the father is the one who told
me
that the father told me that his son
he went away of the deen he is living in
london and he has not been
in his father's house
for how long
for 20 years
can you imagine now are you telling me
that this person will be a successful
person in his life
while he never never ever never
ever and this person he now maybe he is
in his 40s
okay later on he will become on his 70s
and he will die i don't want to use the
word
like maybe any even a dog in
in the west would be you know someone
will look after it
he will die like i don't know
yeah and no one will look after him why
because he was not looking after his
father
so let us let us be practical i want
all the brothers and sisters who are
listening
now this is live yeah
it's not like it's recorded okay right
okay i want all the brothers and sisters
who are listening now
i want them what to go immediately
and to fix their relationship with
their parents and the first thing they
need to do
is what call your mom and call your dad
and fix your relationship with them
this is the first step towards what
towards
real happiness contentment and success
how do you deal with before i get into
the ayahs of quran and the hadith
how do you deal with excuses because
everybody has some kind of reason
justification the person will say look
my father never told me he loved me
he's not the father that i saw in the tv
shows
what do you say to that [ __ ] excuses
yeah excuse it see
and then and then and then and then a
son a son some will even say you know
i'm ready to go in front of the court of
allah
because of these excuses i'm ready to go
the person yeah
yeah see the prophet says
the reason for us commanded to
be kind to our parents is not because
they looked after us see
if there is a father yeah or a mother
they had the child and the child was
brought up by someone else
he was taken by social services or
was maybe the father abandoned him or
the mother
abandoned her child let us imagine and
then
later on yeah the
the child came to know about his mother
or father
he must he must look after them
yeah even if they abandoned him
even if they did not care for him even
for one single day
because it is not reciprocal yeah
it is not they paid me i pay them back
no
it is because they give birth to you
and the reason for you to exist on this
earth is them full stop
this meaning unfortunately many speakers
many uh
they are not focusing on it and that's
why
we see righteous people who may be not
in touch with their parents
and i say to them
yeah and here in the west if
yani you if your father abused you or
whatever then he is not your father
anymore no no
this is wrong yes
if they took care of you no
when allah
the ruling or the rights of parents
and the rights of mother for example for
one
one reason which is what that she bought
him
in her tummy and then she gave birth to
him
that's all yeah and then
allah gave more right once because he
has
breastfed him but just by
being his mother or her mother
this is more than enough by being
his father or her father this
is enough for the parents to have
their rights upon you no excuses
no excuses and on the other side
i would like to say to you brothers and
sisters
that if you know
that if your parents were
not nice to you they were you know
they were abusing you whatever
once you look after them wallahi the
reward will be doubled
because now you are doing it for the
sake of allah
and not only that allah allah will
give you the best in your children
so you are the first one to benefit
you are the first one to benefit however
if you don't look after them
you are the first loser in this life
and in the hereafter recently i came
across
a book in arabic
i hate my father and in that book
it says that see you hate him or you
don't hate him
and he he went through some yanni some
issues maybe
the other the child as you said his
father never told him i love you etc
but he said one of the
key strong points at the end of the day
you need to look after your father for
your own success
and when children they say i am not
moving on in my life
a check you will find that they have
very bad
relationship with their parents uh
and see i would like to say yeah
let me be honest because i mix with
young people
speak to them a lot let me be honest
many young people they what they use
execuses for their own failure
they put it on their parents yeah and
i don't know whether i have mentioned
this or not one time i was
approached by a young person and he told
me i want to
you know have a private chat with me or
with you okay
he said i am a failing person okay
habibi why are you failing
he said because i remember was i i
remember once that my father
was telling my mother that this child is
failing
i said and then you became yeah
failing person because of this yeah he
said well
yeah i said habibi you are fooling
yourself
you are failing because you want to fail
not because of your father
forget about your father i am sure he
wanted the best for you
yeah you might say there are exceptions
of course
all the children they say that there are
exceptions yeah
but i am sure he wants the best for you
but imagine that he was not
like this uh what what you need to move
on
you need to move on you cannot get stuck
if you get stuck you will harm yourself
and by the way maya be one time we need
to speak about
this issue of one of the main reasons
for mental illnesses
which is what living in the past
one of the can you repeat that so one of
the main causes
this is very this is a very uh a
profound statement you just made so one
of the profound
one of the key reasons for mental
illness could be
living in the past living in the past if
what the key if not the key reason for
many mental illness yeah if
the key yes is what i think in the past
what does it living in the past you know
that's why the prophet sallallahu alaihi
sallam says
yeah be careful of what had i done
yes
had i done this had i done this
had i done this it will open what the
doors for the shape on
and most of the people who are going
through mental illnesses that i have
seen
and by the way i speak to any number of
er psychologists and psychiatrists
frequently because my work as a shaykh
has a mufti as
i give a lot of counselling so i take
help from them now i am dealing with one
of yani you can say relatives and he is
going
through very bad depression and
the key reason for him to go through
this
is what living in the past
regretting for something that has what
that has been
done yeah
tell me shay so now we have i got a
bunch of questions here
so we have so many ayahs uh for example
in the quran let's talk about so we
talked about family
and then now you have siblings you know
and and this
can be something you know for for my
children for
you know others children's you leave
behind something good that they can come
back to
and and hopefully you know reflect over
because uh
you have a lot of the breakdown of the
family because of the civility rivalry
and the boycotting of when i say
brothers i'll say also this is including
sister and sister brother and brother
but then some of these ayahs and you can
tell us what do we take from it one the
believers are nothing
else but brothers in in the deen so make
reconciliation between your brothers and
then another ayah
and fear god allah through whom you
demand your mutual rights and do not cut
off the
ties of the of kinship again another
ayah fear allah and reconcile the bonds
that have been broken between you so
they go on and on
from the quran and then you have this
hadith
mentioned there's two versions of ishia
can you tell us
the other one one is in bihari where it
says do not desert one another
do not uh do not nurse hatred towards
one another do not be jealous of one
another and become fellow brothers and
slaves of allah
it is not lawful for a muslim to stop
talking to his brother
for more than three days this is a
muslim but is this one authentic also
it's an abu dhabu
we don't hear this one it says it's not
lawful for a muslim to forsake his
brother for more than three days and
whoever it does so for more than three
days and then dies on it will certainly
enter the hell fire
so what's your comment when you yeah see
and actually i want i wanted to quote
this hadith
brothers whether this the last part of
the hadith
is authentic or it is weak but we cannot
confirm
but the general meaning is there see if
the prophet sallallahu alaihi sallam is
talking about this
talking about those who are what just
not blood brothers
it is not allowed yeah for a muslim
to boycott his brother in islam
for what more than three days what about
your
own blood brother
yeah that's why this is a major sin
and that's why maybe this narration that
if the person
dies like this he deserves the fire of
hell
because he is dying on a major
sin but someone will say shay but
someone will say hold on
uh he needs time you know or she needs
time and they'll say okay he's he's
needs to get himself together so six
months will pass
seven months will pass and then there's
leave the person alone how do you
respond
i mean what's the right approach then
yeah these
are just excuses and now
so many people whenever you tell them
something
yeah they always use this excuse
brother why don't you pray i need time
okay i'm sure
10 years ago someone told you why don't
you pray and you said you need time yes
or no
subhanallah it is
they are the they are what using and
execute
this is number one number two what about
you what about if you die before the
time comes
are you sure give me any confirmation
that you are going to live and then i
will give you what
i will give you time yeah this is number
two
number three the shaitaan
more likely will make more hatred
yeah the hater it will increase so you
need to cut
the way yeah of the shaytan and then
go directly that's why
the prophet saw i mean one of the
narration he said
the best of them is the one who what
the first one to start this
one of the companions went to the
prophet salam and he said
i have some relatives and i maintain the
ties of kenship
but they cut it i'm intend they cut i
maintain they cut
yeah so ya rasulullah what shall i do
he said no you need to continue to do
that the meaning of what the prophet
sallam said because you are actually
feeding them with what
when the person is on deathbed
yeah he will regret so many things
and he will say oh please call my
brother
call my sister let them forgive me i
want to do this and that
okay another important point which is
your children
yeah brothers sisters wake up wake up
please your children will copy
the way you were what treating your own
brothers and sisters so don't see don't
say
that or my children now they are very
nice with each other etc
yeah no once you die
they will remember how you used to treat
your brothers
and sisters whether you were tolerant
whether you were
maintaining the ties of kinship visiting
them
loving them showing respect tolerating
forgiving them etc they will do the same
if you were and
see we have we have example
of parents telling their children oh
look
your uncle is this and that and evil
your auntie is this and that sir
many people are doing this your
children will do the same thing to each
other once you pass away
this is life yeah
so what should a person do the one who
is trying to
on the other receiving end the person
doesn't want to fall
into this major sin this haram so the
person is trying to reconcile with their
brother sister they're trying their best
but every time
now they're getting resistance family
members are also saying just leave it
alone
what should that person do are they
absorbed what do they do
no they should continue to stop simple
but how what like how how should they
continue like what
are they try different ways but try
different ways
sometimes by sending gifts sometimes by
sending salam
sometimes by calling sometimes by
visiting sometimes
send your children yeah
because if i have something with my with
my brother
i should not let my children boycott him
he should not let his children boycott
me
i should my i should send my children i
should
teach them no respect your uncle respect
your cousin
make sure that you you communicate with
them
yeah this is the way and see
let us not think that people are evil
when i keep trying
and the other side their hearts will be
soft
and one time their hearts will
be insulted now is there in a situation
where
some people will say okay now they'll
start to use the psychiatry of this time
psychology
so is there is there things that we'll
take from
it but then when it conflicts like a
person will justify
okay a person has boundaries respect
their bound so they'll quote now
they'll quote uh psychology
psychiatrists and
psychologists and whatnot in this matter
so then what do you do like you have
dean here and then you have over here
you know yeah exactly that's why
you know we sometimes there are major
conflicts
and you know although i am a person who
likes psychology a lot
and i read in it but we need islamic
psychology
because sometimes you know the
non-islamic
psychology can be harmful i'll give you
an example
okay now psychiatrists
they like labeling people
yeah you go to and they say oh you have
very bad
very bad depression and once the person
hears this what will happen he will
internalize this
yeah and once the person internalizes
this
he will use this as an excuse or
he will use this as excuses for so many
things
and we have seen that okay why don't you
do this i am i have depression
the other day uh about fasting yeah well
she has anxiety
and if she fast then yeah but but
is this is it really linked okay
well yeah she has anxiety uh
other other ocd yeah
other problems by what those
problems will be if the person will
internalize them will
be embedding them once the person
is labeled like this that's why
from an islamic perspective from an
islamic perspective
it focuses it doesn't focus on labels it
focuses on what
actions yeah because
yeah this action is wrong i can get rid
of it but if i
am a classified as a depressed person
even if i can do things correctly no i
am depressed
yeah so i will act accordingly that
makes a lot of sense tell us
another hadith where the prophet saw is
talking about
that the deeds of allah this is in
muslim
are presented to allah on mondays and
thursdays and then
every slave of allah is granted
forgiveness he does not associate
anything partners with allah and worship
but except the person
who's now can you go ahead and finish
this and tell us what this hadith is
talking about
on mondays and thursdays and as we know
that when the
mondays prophet lot he was asked and he
said this is a day
the deeds go uh are raised to allah and
i like my deeds to
be raised to allah allah when i am
fasting in this narration
the prophet salallahu said that allah
will forgive those who did not commit
any kind of shirt
but those who have what boycott each
other
and these are not the brothers the blood
brothers
no these are not the relatives no
they are who yeah the
normal people allah
allah will say no no don't forgive them
until what
they reconcile subhanallah so your deeds
are you technically are you technically
your prayer you're fasting right in
ramadan
it you're like is it technically you
like almost sabotaging your deeds
because you're boycotting your brother
your sister
exactly exactly that's why we are yani
that's why i am
a bit emotional about this thing i want
brothers and sisters to wake up
is not an easy issue it's not an easy
issue
this is what these are again not your
blood brothers
but they are just muslims
yeah but what if it's now so you're
saying that's even more severe if these
are blood
brothers and sisters of course
of course if they are relatives what
about your parents
and that's why what about [ __ ] what
about but now the excuses come in now
the sister the brother says they he
wronged me
via b and uh you know when i was young
he hit me
or he you know did this did that
and the list of excuses start to come up
what about that
is there justification there yeah all of
these are excuses
that maintaining the ties of kinship
with him is something yeah see from an
islam islam is a very
really realistic way
it says that well this is something
and this is something else this person
committed this mistake it doesn't mean
that we what
shunned him off completely and we forget
about
all of his rights no he deserves
to be punished for that whether in this
life
or in the hereafter but from the other
side
he what has certain rights
this does not justify this we say in
english
yeah uh what is it uh two errors will
not make
any uh what is it two rounds don't make
a right
yes two what two wrongs don't make a
right
yeah two runs will not make one right
okay so he responded to you he
treated you badly it doesn't mean that
you
do the same thing because that is wrong
that is wrong it doesn't make it
right yeah and that's why
that is
if a person you have something with him
deter
the evil with what with doing good
so as a result if there is a person you
have
hatred against him he is your enemy
but because you responded to his evil
in a very nice way we are not talking
about
uh the enemy of islam and muslims no no
no we are not talking about that we are
talking about
a normal person a muslim a believer
who is generally speaking not evil
yeah but you think that he wronged you
then
what will happen once you respond in the
best way
then you will be as close friends and
let me just say one important
point about this many brothers and
sisters they
enjoy looking at themselves as victims
yeah they like oh look everyone is
against me
yeah when i was young yeah my parents my
parents were against me my parents
used to favor the other child my
my other siblings my elder brothers they
used to beat me up
they used to take my things i used to
get the
old clothes i used to get the second
handy clothes after they
wear it i was yeah they like to what
to victimize themselves they enjoy it
because what because this victimizations
lead to many justifications of many of
their mistakes
brothers and sisters a successful person
will not victimize himself
yeah the successful person will move
will keep moving will keep moving that's
why
to keep moving go and fix your
relationship
with your siblings and with your
relatives in general just a couple more
uh
that we want to share with you sheikh
can this next hadith that's narrated
can you tell us can this be now
encouraging
people to get involved where you hear
the prophet saying
asking the question do you know what is
better far better than charity prayer
fasting they said what could be better
he said bringing
those tithes of kinship together shall i
inform you of something more excellent
degree then fasting prayer
and sadhaka then the people replied yes
so messenger of allah he said it is
putting things right between people
spoiling them of his shaver how do we
understand this hadith
yeah see this is see
islam wants us to remain as
a solid society yeah
once this society is disunited
yeah the whole ummah will be disunited
and then
it will be fragmented and it will be
weakened
yes that's why we say unity starts at
home
and that's why allah allah warned us
against this unity
don't be disunited otherwise what you
will lose courage and your strength will
what
will depart that's why you know
those who maintain the relationship
between people
reconcile between people they have they
are doing
one of the best deeds if not the best
deeds
yeah and this is what the prophet sallam
says shall i tell you about
that which is better than
in the quran
building the bridges and fixing the
relationship
between people see we are allowed to lie
we are allowed to lie in order to what
to fix the relationship between people
see how much weight and exceptions allah
for this process which is what
reconciling between
people so this falls into so nobody so
nobody gets the wrong impression this
falls under those categories
specifically
if let's say your wife makes you some
food too much salt in it or whatnot like
hey you know
how is it yeah it's great honey or this
to bring unity together
this is an exception for that but in
general lying is is
detested it's a it's a it's something
that's totally
you know you're not supposed to lie but
in this case
yeah of course this is well known and we
don't need to yeah
okay to clarify that but for example a
and b
and you go to a yeah a and b they have
problems
and these are not blood brothers by the
way and then you go to a and you say you
know what
i the other day i was with b and he told
me that you know
i love a and you know but i'm lying
for that for the reconciliation not
lying about anything else
yeah and you go to a and you tell him
that listen
you know b told me that i want to
reconcile with a but
i feel that if i may reconcile he might
misunderstand me or he might
you know put me off or so then he will
say
really yeah really and then you got to
be
and you tell them the same thing in
order to what
to fix the relationship this is what
this
is allowed and this is the the scholars
mentioned it is
some of the scholars mention this as a
comment on this
yeah and they said this kind of secret
yeah hidden discussion uh a
hidden discussion in an isolated way
which it is not allowed in general
yeah except
except if you are doing these good
things including what
including fixing the relationship
between people
okay shay just one more hadith and a
story and we know that we strive i mean
to be on
pure monotheism to worship the creator
not the creation the one and only
creator of the heavens and the earth the
same god of moses jesus abraham the last
of the final message of muhammad peace
and blessings be upon him
all they glad to get glad tidings of
what we're striving for to avoid the
hellfire and to get to
jannah that's why we're fasting this
month of ramadan
praying doing all of these good deeds
now to hear this hadith this is uh in
buhari
you know it's really scary and and
should hopefully you know rattle some of
the emotions of someone to go ahead and
you know uh make men's with their
brother or sister it says one does not
enter paradise who breaks
up his family ties
so this is in bukhari this authentic
hadith
i mean what do you say about that [ __ ]
so
i need the person the person who
dies while uh he is still
did not fix the relationship with his uh
with his relatives yeah he will be
stopped before getting into jannah
until what if he has rights or they have
rights
until that is fixed between what between
his uh between his his relatives
some scholars said that
means that he should be punished before
jen before getting to jannah because he
has committed a major sin
of course here it doesn't mean
permanently
because we as you know i listen now we
believe that
even if the person committed a major sin
yeah
eventually he will be purified from that
major sin
and will go to jannah but this shows the
severity
of this what of this uh
sin this is why it's so important to go
to a scholar like yourself you know
people of knowledge to go ahead and get
clarification context of such
hadith now there's a story that we want
to end with
and the story goes like this i don't
know if you probably have heard it's a
is attributed to abu harer one of the
companions of the prophet said a young
man went to attend the weekly
halaqa lecture of abu hara
but stop when he heard him saying if
anyone sitting here has severe ties a
kinship
he should leave so the story continues
said he recalled that he had not been on
speaking terms with his aunt
living in the same town the young man
quickly left the gathering and went
straight to his hand's house and
asked for forgiveness for his past
behavior and sought sought forgiveness
when the ant inquired about the reason
for the change of heart
he narrated the incident the story
continues she accepted the apology but
asked him
to inquire from abu hared the reason for
this
unusual statement why did abu hura leave
all the other major sins and focus
only on this what was so special about
the ties of kinship
replied that he had heard the prophet
saw some
narrate that our deeds were presented to
allah every thursday night and
anyone who had severed family ties
has his good deeds rejected he did not
want any such person sitting in his
gathering
which was held on the same night for
fear that it could deprive the entire
gathering
of the blessings of allah
how do we take the story shake how do we
take this story is this authentic how do
we like
yeah yeah okay this is speaks for itself
this is speaks for itself that's why we
and i appeal to imams to
you to focus on this yeah
on this issue maintaining the ties of
kinship
and to show yes to narrate the verses
between what commanding to worship alone
and what
not to be rude to your parents and to
look after them
allah allah says thank me
be thankful to me and to your parents
yeah in particular and uh and
and see the the one of the
there are so many stories one of the uh
one of the people came to um
and said to him you know what my mother
became
ill and disabled and in order for
her to relieve herself she cannot
relieve herself except if she sit on my
back so she sits on my back
uh wanted to relieve herself i turn away
and i don't look at her
yeah this is the way she can relieve
herself
so omar do you think that i have
fulfilled her life
and then um he said no no no
no ever he said how come how come
she and this is the way she relieves
herself yeah defecates or
urinate yeah on my back when i'm
carrying her
he said yeah because she did the same
thing
when you were young and she wanted you
to continue
and to grow and to become you know to
see you as a man
but now you want to get rid of
this yeah look yeah
he was not sorry
he could not eat with his mother he said
why
because i was afraid that i might
eat something that she was thinking of
eating it one person asked one of the
scholars
can i argue with my father he said you
cannot
stare at him
just staring at him you want see we can
go
on and on by talking about those stories
anyway just because of time those
stories speak volumes and wallahi i feel
sorry for
our young people in the west yeah
in non-muslim countries in general
because
these values are not there
are not common they are not used to
these values
and that's why even from adawa
perspective
i when you know when they talk about
american values british values
i say on in this in those valleys the
most
important value which is what
yeah looking after your parents
yeah maintaining that house of kinship
and the impact of that
is on social cohesion the welfare
the well-being of the society the
security
you name it and still none of those
countries consider it as what as a
value now in fact in to contrary of that
if your father yeah if you the father
you know
i i don't know whether i mentioned this
or not to you or to i mentioned it
one of these sisters one teacher here
he told me that he one of the girls
she founded the police for her parents
because they stopped what the wi-fi
yeah so this is now the culture
unfortunately and we need campaigns
uh inshallah we will be doing a campaign
like this which is
look after your pen something like this
all right last closing comments and
advice now the person
we talked about the parent and now
finishing off for
the brother or sister who's boycotting
each other
they're tuning in last minute that we
have what advice do you have for them to
help maybe soften
his her heart so they can reconcile on
his blessed month of ramadan
says i swear by allah nothing
more sweeter in your heart and nothing
that will soften your heart and makes
you closer to allah
than suppressing your ego
and what and call your parents first of
all
and then your siblings and the other
relatives
and you will see the impact of this on
your life in your contentment on your
happiness
on your children on your life in general
sheikh thank you so much thank you so
much inshallah this can go down in
history and help
to go ahead and mend some relationship
and bring much good
to the homes that have been broken
jazakallah thank you shay
radhika